[Música]
nicaragua vuelve a estar en el centro de
la polémica a nivel internacional ahora
el gobierno del presidente daniel ortega
es criticado por diferentes sectores por
la ola de ataques de su gobierno a los
líderes de la iglesia que eran tal vez
los pocos que todavía podían seguir
elevando una voz crítica e independiente
contra el gobierno ortega murillo
el obispo rolando álvarez fue detenido
luego de que la policía allanó su
residencia y lo puso bajo arresto
domiciliario otros ocho de sus
colaboradores están también en la cárcel
los cargos pues van desde un supuesto
abuso infantil hasta la alteración del
orden público ninguno ha sido condenado
por la justicia nicaragüense hasta el
momento los pocos clérigos o misioneros
religiosos que han quedado en ese país
centroamericano han sido sometidos a
campañas de miedo ellos mismos han
reportado que las autoridades les
prohibieron que la iglesia nicaragüense
realice procesiones religiosas en las
calles también impidieron oficiar misas
e incluso e incluso estacionaron
patrullas de la policía frente a sus
parroquias y algo los sacerdotes incluso
también fueron interrogados por las
autoridades este nuevo capítulo de
represión de ortega nicaragua se suma a
lo que ha hecho contra otros sectores de
la sociedad de ese país ya cerca de 200
políticos empresarios líderes sociales
líderes estudiantiles y periodistas han
sido encarcelados en el último año
veamos entonces lo que dijo la iglesia
católica nicaragüense al respecto a
través de un comunicado de prensa
el señor arzobispo cardenal leopoldo
brenes tuvo la oportunidad de visitar y
conversar con monseñor álvarez en su
residencia familiar
patentizando su estima fraterna en
nombre de nuestra iglesia nicaragüense
si bien su condición física está
desmejorada a su ánimo y espíritu están
fuertes monseñor álvarez le ha
manifestado su confianza en la oración
de todos ante esta difícil situación que
vivimos en comunidad eclesial
cuál es entonces el rumbo que el
presidente daniel ortega quiere darle a
su país al reprimir tal parece que a
todas las voces que sean críticas o que
discrepan de sus políticas porque tiene
lugar esta persecución puntual contra la
iglesia católica como ha sido a lo largo
de los años esa relación entre la
iglesia católica nicaragüense y el
sandinismo es un punto de quiebre para
la historia política de ese país porque
la comunidad internacional ya está el
mismo vaticano es tímido a la hora de
pedir explicaciones y de hacer algún
tipo de señalamientos a estas acciones
por parte del gobierno ortega pues lo
vamos a analizar hoy en nuestro programa
para conversar sobre este tema hemos
invitado a ocampo ella es abogada
periodista ex diputada por el partido
frente sandinista de liberación nacional
ella se encuentra justamente en managua
la capital nicaragüense y desde ciudad
de panamá se conecta israel el ebit es
el es activista y exiliado nicaragüense
vale la pena decir que france24 intentó
consultar y convocar para este programa
a representantes tanto del gobierno de
nicaragua como de la iglesia católica de
ese país para conocer posiciones
oficiales sobre esta situación y hasta
ahora no hemos obtenido ningún tipo de
respuesta a nuestras solicitudes eso sí
les recuerdo que ustedes también hacen
parte de esta conversación pueden dejar
sus preguntas y comentarios en nuestras
redes sociales estamos en twitter en
instagram y en facebook en donde nos
encuentran como france24
s arroba santi logo que es mi cuenta
personal la etiqueta es numeral en el
debate efe 24 en youtube también pueden
seguir nuestra señal en streaming en
vivo y en directo pueden dejar sus
comentarios a través del chat en vivo y
saludamos a las personas que nos están
escuchando a través del podcast todos
los contenidos del programa ya están
disponibles en diferentes las formas
estamos en el podcast en spotify deezer
y yum
desde entonces la bienvenida de xóchitl
en la ciudad de managua en la capital
nicaragüense punto de partida xóchitl
bienvenida primera pregunta para conocer
posiciones sobre este tema porque atacar
a la iglesia católica porque esta
persecución a que le debe le teme el
presidente ortega que la iglesia pueda
dar a conocer al mundo
muchas gracias por la invitación
nuevamente por querer escuchar un
criterio una opinión distinta a la que
manejan a la línea editorial que manejan
algodones de comunicación extranjeros
obviamente lo que existe en una campaña
de desprestigio en contra de nicaragua
en contra del gobierno y este campaña en
el exterior porque nicaragua esas
campañas no han dado resultado de sus
intentos golpistas no han tenido
resultados de tal manera que esto
únicamente se quiere inflar en el
exterior hacer campaña que desprestigien
al pueblo nicaragüense y al gobierno que
obviamente es en parte el interés y
quiénes son los que están detrás aquí el
gobierno estadounidense siempre ha sido
el promotor de la intentona golpista el
frente independiente especialmente el
gobierno de nicaragua no tiene ninguna
ofensiva no tiene ninguna campaña de
compra en la iglesia lastimosamente eran
contrario hay algunos gente que se gana
bloque hay algunos líderes de la iglesia
católica que lamentablemente ocupan su
sotana ocupan su envestidura para hacer
proselitismo político inclusive se han
dedicado desde el 2018 que se logró
volpi está se han dedicado a querer
levantar al pueblo que se levante contra
el gobierno y prácticamente ocupan su
liderazgo religioso para hacer política
se vuelven líderes político y ayudando
que está condenando duramente el pueblo
por ejercicio político entonces que
dejen de ser de caer en de querer
parecer líderes religiosos aquí o son
religiosos que debes dedicarte a
promover el cristianismo el amor al
prójimo el amor a dios sobre todas las
cosas o un líder político que entonces
xavi de la iglesia estamos utilizando
y esa iglesia esos templos sagrados para
estar protegiendo a delincuentes que
destruimos en 2018 y estar haciendo
política
en pocas palabras en tejerías
normalmente perfecta una intentona
golpista este es el contexto que
actualmente se vive en tramos mejor el
gobierno 700 y no abajo aquí no están
con la iglesia católica por encontrarlo
hay muchos líderes religiosos que están
trabajando muy bien de la mano con el
pueblo con el gobierno y están
celebrando mis la contabilidad incluso
hace poco se realizó la gritería la
chiquita como se le llama en el
departamento de león o sea no es por
toda la iglesia es con ciertos líderes
lamentablemente deportistas es una
iglesia para hacer tu lee si israel le
doy la bienvenida al programa usted se
encuentra en ciudad de panamá la misma
pregunta como punto de partida porque
este ataque la iglesia a que le teme el
presidente ortega cuál es su perspectiva
la dictadura de daniel ortega ha venido
sistemáticamente a callando todas las
voces que puedan mostrar una misma
disidencia a su régimen como vimos
encarceló a cualquier precandidato
político que intentó desafiarlo en
elecciones
anuló la autonomía universitaria
a los periodistas los mandó al exilio la
gran mayoría a otros secuestros cerró
los medios de comunicación
independientes las cámaras de comercio
como el cosep y medio expresó a los
líderes empresariales
también ha venido con sus tridente de
leyes atemorizando a toda la población
con
amenazas de cárcel por publicaciones en
redes sociales ha venido anulando todas
las ongs de de índole caritativa de
índole religiosa de índole de ciencia la
hasta la real academia española la que
fue prohibida en
nicaragua y el último bastión que
quedaba de voz
medianamente independiente eran algunos
púlpitos es donde personas valientes
como hace un monseñor silvio al mar es
que ha sido está en el exilio y ahora lo
que está ocurriendo verdad
simplemente no te muestra qué
de la dictadura lo que está buscando es
acallar la última voz que queda
y lo están logrando en realidad logrado
intimidar a la iglesia el calvario que
está sufriendo el señor rolando álvarez
con 15 días de secuestro y ahora en su
casa rodeado de militares de
la dictadura de ortega nos demuestra que
daniel ortega le está mandando un
mensaje claro a la iglesia católica como
se lo ha mandado a todas las
instituciones
ustedes se callan bajan la cabeza
o van a sufrir las consecuencias de la
represión y la represión ese exilio el
secuestro o el muerte si soy el usted
habla que algunos de los sectores dentro
de la iglesia católica en nicaragüense
están también colaborando en ciertos
aspectos con el gobierno que no son
todos los que están siendo
puestos en este grupo de personas
detenidas por las autoridades por ser
golpistas pero que hay por ejemplo de
grupos como por ejemplo la misión de la
caridad que es este grupo de monjas
solidarias que fue creado en su momento
la madre de teresa que ya tuvieron que
salir de nicaragua precisamente por los
temas de seguridad y por la represión
que hay contra la iglesia estas monjas
son golpistas para ustedes en serio
la verdad es que no sé la razón por la
cual tuvieron que salir y ya sabrán sus
razones lo que sí sé es que aquí no hay
persecución se ha hecho limpieza en
algunas ong sí probablemente por ahí
viene el tema de ellas porque algunas
ong recibían financiamiento en taquilla
a la ayuda que recibían de la ayuda
internacional para supuestamente hacer
en algún tipo de servicio social en la
comunidad
la joven agencia simplificación sin
fines de lucro pero a la hora de servir
no la quita competente que en el
interior nació más revisar de
funcionamiento resulta que éstas no
vendían pueden nacionales empezaba a
entrar el dinero y no era precisamente
el fin para el juego supuestamente
venían eso ese dinero no se exhibían los
proyectos y no ser utilizados para hacer
otro tipo de cosas en otras palabras se
podría hablar inclusive de lavado de
dinero y otra otro claro pero
social pero bueno eso es especulación
suya no hay ningún argumento que tenga
un sustento de lo que usted me está
diciendo quiero pasar a preguntarles
özil por la relación que ha tenido a lo
largo de la historia de la iglesia
católica con el sandinismo alaya al
momento en que cae la dictadura de
somoza en cierta forma la iglesia y el
sandinismo hicieron una mancuerna una
alianza para llevar a cabo ese proyecto
revolucionario en cierta forma pues se
apoyaba esa transición de gobierno y hoy
el escenario es completamente distinto
como ha sido la relación es se tira y
afloja que había entre la relación de la
iglesia y el sandinismo
bueno en santiago hablar de especulación
cuando estoy contento porque ustedes
también especulan al decir que ya salen
porque estando acá seguida igual esa
especulación porque nada sí pero bueno
cada quien tiene en su forma de ver las
cosas
de la manera que las quieras ver yo te
dedicará al siempre es importante
aclarar eso porque yo aquí veo las cosas
como son y no me las cuentas en el
extranjero
él representa iniciativa nación
nacionalidad quien es importante hablar
del pasado porque recuerdo por tenemos
que aquí la constitución política en
1893 con el presidente zelaya se reformó
y aclaró de que aquí la iglesia está muy
separada muy por aparte del gobierno y
precisamente esa gran constitución la
libérrima en
1896 también está y no dejar claro que
este país es la meta y que aquí se puede
progresar para que la elección de esa
separación gobierno iglesia quedó
marcada desde hace seis años atrás no
desde ahora el precio se administra
desde que retomó el poder en 1980 ha
sido creada a través de la revolución
popular es indistinta que fue una
una victoria del pueblo alegrado claro
de que
te viene gobernada por respeto a la
institución de gobierno y que la
evidencia puede cumplir su misión su
papel que en este caso una meterse en
política no es como dice el señor le
evite desde un púlpito ser valiente no
hay que sentar en la función de un
sacerdote estar haciendo política o
estar llamando al levantamiento social
en
estos inicios y
pensé esta señora para saber que él no
está haciendo cristianismo ocurre con 30
sembrando odio en el corazón de sus
feligreses y está llamando a un
lanzamiento con francisco contra el
gobierno está haciendo política desde el
púlpito inaler ejército le viste nos
reconozca como vivimos pues que le
valiente de los púlpitos y porque que le
está haciendo política me está haciendo
cristianismo entonces el pri también
está vendiendo granados hombre hacia la
institución y obviamente con resistencia
a la iglesia católica y obviamente vimos
la excelente relación que ha tenido que
tuvo durante el tiempo que estuvo el
cardenal miguel obando invitación luego
las excelentes reacciones también tiempo
del cardenal actual pero lastimosamente
algunos cuantos de los líderes
religiosos son terroristas y son
golpistas porque desde el púlpito han
llamado al levantamiento social han
llamado a votar al gobierno incluso hay
una declaración de criterio fue en busca
distantes de uno de uno que se atrevió a
decirle al presidente que lo iban a
asesinar le dijo perry entonces porque
van a matar los perros familia o sea
puedo inclusive éste confesó antes un
delito
claro israel su opinión sobre cómo ha
sido esta relación entre el gobierno del
presidente ortega y la iglesia una
relación que hemos visto se ha venido
deteriorando con el paso de las semanas
de los meses
a lo largo de este último tiempo como
cual cuál es su opinión
la iglesia es una organización es un
estado católico bastante complejo en
donde hay distintas corrientes en los
años 80 tuvimos a una teología de
liberación turbó al padre ernesto
cardenal que se posicionaba al lado del
proyecto sandinista desde entonces y al
papa juan pablo segundo que era crítico
de
esta política
en el
retorno de daniel ortega el escenario ha
sido digamos
bastante menos polarizado la iglesia ha
realizado pues su gestión bastante al
margen de lo que es
el régimen de ortega que se ha venido
que se vino consolidando gradualmente
como una dictadura y es hasta cuando ya
los abusos y las violaciones a los
derechos humanos son absolutamente
evidentes y los atropellos son tan
atroces que una serie de líderes
religiosos no pueden dejar de lado los
los líderes más comprometidos por el
pueblo no pueden dejar de lado el su
prédica
mencionar los abusos y las cosas que
están incorrectas en el país porque
finalmente parte del llamado en la
iglesia y de las enseñanzas de jesús
según interpreto es no mantener oídos
sordos no mantenerse al completamente al
margen cuando están ocurriendo una serie
de atrocidades en contra del pueblo
entonces una serie de pastores en
nicaragua
ha analizado una voz nunca de violencia
pero sí de reflexión ante lo que está
ocurriendo y bueno tenemos a más de diez
pastores religiosos sacerdotes que están
actualmente secuestrados por la
dictadura impresos totalmente ilegales
porque todas estas argumentaciones que
menciona que la señora nuestra
respaldada por investigaciones no están
respaldadas por orden judicial es
nuestra respaldada por ninguna prueba
simplemente secuestran al señor durante
15 días diciendo lo está investigando y
nosotros secuestran nadal secuestran a
varias personas más adentro de una
iglesia luego entra rompiendo las
puertas a las 3 de la mañana un
allanamiento totalmente ilegal sin
ninguna orden coautor vayan a miento
tienen que ser re 6 de la mañana a 6 de
la tarde y luego la mente en casa por
cárcel tampoco sin ninguna prueba sin
ningún informe sin derecho a la defensa
nada y así como estamos viendo esta
violación de derechos humanos al
monseñor así ha sido con más de 205
presos políticos que actualmente están
en las cárceles viola nocheros o derecho
y me y mencionó el caso de personas ni
siquiera se les permite ver a sus hijos
por más de un año que se mantiene el
empleo en el zelda de aislamiento soy
finado durante 14 meses discúlpame özil
aquí lo que uno puede ver desde fuera y
de este rompecabezas que poder o
normando de la situación allí en
nicaragua o tal vez lo que uno vio desde
el 2018 cuando comenzó ese levantamiento
popular de los estudiantes por esta
decisión del gobierno de nicaragua hacer
esta reforma al seguro social es que tal
vez la iglesia se mostró a favor de los
manifestantes y apoyo en cierta forma a
estos manifestantes y esto mostró el
poder que tenía la iglesia sobre la
población sobre nicaragua un país que es
más del 90 por ciento de su población se
declara como católica el temor es la
fuerza que puede tomar la iglesia de
pronto desde esas bases contradictorias
al presidente ortega a eso es a lo que
le teme el gobierno
pues aquí hay varias cosas interesantes
que menciona dice que él la iglesia
apoyo a estos golpistas y aquí están las
imágenes donde miramos que nada
prácticamente irrumpieron la violencia
en el altar ante el señor de la
corrección para dioses y hombres
encapuchados con armas de guerra y esos
mismos queremos que levantar mientras
que mi marcado violaron y si quiero
besarte en el país hay es una
coincidencia católica si tiene razón
sigue sin llegar los levantamientos
sociales y me decirle que nada si estos
son golpistas que vivieron a demandas
también de la muerte y asesinar a más de
100 personas en mi cabeza de tres o
cuatro días militantes del frente
sandinista a todo que se opusiera a otra
parte con un tiempo para el gobierno
ellos venían tomando tortura a esos
órganos que apoyó la exacta porque
efectivamente no todos los padres porque
como le digo aquí podemos sacerdote pero
hay otros que se enredaron y son
golpistas y han estado respondiendo a
una cosa política de ultraderecha de
derecha la misma que apoya el señor le
evite porque si él está en panamá que
dice que decía alá el derecho a la
derecha financia bajo
de eeuu
no podemos hacerlo si no sentís
que se atengan a decidir el intesa
católica lamentablemente ha venido
bajando el nivel del porcentaje de
cesión en el país de amama 50% que en
años anteriores ha venido disminuyendo
precisamente por el descontento con la
anomalía que se da y ahora en diversidad
ante la clave de un auge porque el mismo
regresa público el mismo católico está
desplazando ya esa mala dirección que ha
tenido la iglesia católica en el país ya
tenemos descontento el precio sandinista
está haciendo su trabajo está haciendo
carretera hospital está llevando la
salud gratuita está llevando
alimentación tránsito en pueblo yo creo
que un católico christian adulta debería
de apoyar mensajes desde un gobierno ama
pero apoyan es el beneficio social de
una mejor economía de ir bajando la de
50 social eso eso cuánto está torrico
apoyan a la otra dirección la
derechamente país y queremos transmitir
con el últimamente de electro que es
democrático y que está llevando el
progreso a los más pobres a los más
necesitados o sea la mayoría
entonces si por el contrario esto ha
dejado en evidencia que la iglesia
católica tiene ser un problema en su
dirección
lamentable yo le quiero recordar esto 18
cuando llegaba los jerarcas de la
iglesia católica del hubiese con el
presidente y el pueblo feliz porque
pensábamos que iba a ser un diálogo que
apoyara cuando supuestamente eran un
mediadores y sabemos que alegaron han
sido el presidente rinda se deje el
cargo del gobierno el psoe llegue a ser
de 300 no eso ser un siervo el pita eso
dejar a un lado el cristianismo el
fomentar el odio el terrorismo y el
suelo que se está persiguiendo ahora yo
solamente permítame aclararle algo para
que quede claro ellos no están detenidos
mientras son investigados y si se lo
sacarán de la iglesia muy porque que
dice atrincheró mensaje en su trinchera
política y estaba llamamos levantamiento
social en contra del gobierno o sea
siguen con intentona golpista para
preservar la tranquilidad y la paz y lo
más sagrado del pueblo de cinco de su
iglesia y él está siendo investigado
pero mismo
quiero quiero aclarar que en ningún
momento dije la palabra que la iglesia
apoyaba a los golpistas de utilice la
palabra manifestantes que es muy
diferente a golpistas porque quiero
aclarar en una democracia la gente se
puede expresar libremente y expresar su
descontento y discrepar de muchas
políticas del gobierno y no
necesariamente tiene que ser víctima de
represión como si vivimos en escenarios
a lo largo del 2018 en nicaragua quiero
hacer esa aclaración porque en ningún
momento dije golpistas como xóchitl está
diciendo que yo dije en la pregunta pasó
a preguntarle entonces a israel sobre
cómo se puede solucionar este tipo de
discrepancias aquí hay margen para que
la jerarquía de la iglesia nicaragüense
lo que queda de ellas y en este país
pueda negociar israel pueda conversar
directamente con el gobierno
nicaragüense
para dejar de ser víctima de esta
persecución y también para retomar de
pronto ese papel que estaba jugando en
el 2018 después del levantamiento
en las calles que era uno de los
mediadores uno de los
de esta negociación la iglesia puede
recuperar esa posición
israel
hola si israel
tuve un poquito de problema aunque
repito rápidamente la pregunta es el
papel de la iglesia ancha como mediador
si si puede recuperarlo si la jerarquía
de la iglesia tiene todavía margen para
volver a sentarse a conversar con ortega
no solamente por la situación específica
de la iglesia sino también por la
situación que se está viviendo en
general en el país a nivel político y
social
lamento lo que voy a decir pero
creo que
y la dictadura de ortega dejó claro hace
mucho tiempo que ahí no existe ningún
margen de diálogo la dictadura desde
hace mucho decidió
imponerse por medio de sangre y fuego y
atrincherarse el país sin importar los
costos económicos políticos y de vidas
humanas que esto pueda cambiarlo
creo que daniel ortega ha dejado claro
él va a estar hasta el fin
por medio de las armas y creo que lo que
necesitamos más que estar hablando de
diálogos debemos estar pensando en
posiciones de aislamiento muchísimo más
severas en donde el el círculo de hierro
que se lucra con este sistema perverso
empieza a cuestionarse sus lealtades y
el ejército debe estar del lado de la
dictadura y se ponga al lado del pueblo
para buscar la transición democrática
que tanto le urge a nuestro país
eso sí y cuál es su perspectiva para
bajar tensiones con la iglesia católica
nicaragüense hay posibilidades de
diálogo puede la iglesia recuperar ese
papel como mediador entre la sociedad
los diferentes sectores y el gobierno de
daniel ortega como lo ve usted
y desde mi
concepción porque yo no soy del gobierno
siempre lo digo pero yo creo de que la
música sería más que imposible y poco
recomendable porque cuando una persona
va a surgir de mediadoras en una
negociación social o te gusta que sea
imparcial pero te puedo a poner una
persona que ya está parcializada desde
el inicio inclusive que fue parte de la
intentona golpista obviamente no está
calificada está preparada es
recomendable para que sea mediadora ante
esta situación por lo tanto ellos creo
que perdieron una oportunidad de oro en
donde tuvieron en 2018 una mesa de
anuncios como haber sido muy beneficiosa
para el pueblo nicaragüense con él la
paz pero la iglesia católica
lamentablemente no fue imparcial fue
definitivamente parte elsa fue de la
golpista y por lo tanto no hay
condiciones para que ellos puedan ser en
ningún momento radiadores que ante una
deuda dor ahora el gobierno siempre está
abierto al entendimiento al llamado pero
no
como le digo hacernos docente como
llamar a una persona por ejemplo ante el
señor aquí le dimos entrado al frente
como le va a decir venga un diálogo si
no ha dejado de promover el odio se le
sienten los geo que sale de su metraje
ellos no no no no llevan la palabra es
tedioso que hammond en reconciliación
incitan al odio llamada levantamiento
social les conduce en el gobierno
quieren que el por qué no se vaya
entonces o no son líderes por qué tipo
subir no son de este tipo son líderes
políticos que están siempre promoviendo
la intentona golpista por lo tanto bajo
ningún punto de vista podemos ser
mediador una persona que está totalmente
parcial y exacta
xóchitl en ese orden de ideas hubo mucha
expectativa por parte de la comunidad
católica sobre lo que podría decir el
papá francisco sobre este tema porque
directamente están siendo detenidos
sacerdotes que pues de una cierta forma
el papá puede ser la cabeza es el jefe
de ellos en esta organización religiosa
el papá dio unas declaraciones muy
cortas la cito rápidamente quisiera
expresar mi convicción y mi deseo de que
por medio de un diálogo abierto y
sincero se pueda todavía encontrar las
bases para una convivencia respetuosa y
pacífica a ustedes allí les importa lo
que diga el papá francisco al sandinismo
le importa la opinión del papá francisco
por estas acciones que han realizado los
últimos días
por supuesto que nos agrada y tengo una
figura respetada no sólo por los
católicos inclusive soy cristiana y
católica y veo con agrado muchos demás
planteamientos que el país o inclusive
cuando escuchaba a que sin representante
el homenaje de la iglesia nos comentará
en el novio que fueran fuentes de amor
de unidad y que no se metieran en
política un llamado de su interiormente
ahora en un título más ok aunque el
diálogo de reconciliación y esa debería
de ser la línea que tú inicio le hemos
pedido a los representantes de la
iglesia católica en el país pero no ha
sido esa la línea que ellos me han
tomado y un tomaron y siguen tomando la
de la confrontación la de odio la de
usar el púlpito para hacer política y yo
creo que ese mensaje es muy importante
para que prime nuestra reflexión hable
lo general de la iglesia y mi canal y el
llamado que está haciendo
en la máxima autorizada yo creo que es
bueno también que el papá venga a hacer
una revisión a su iglesia porque no son
evitar abajo en muchos países vemos con
las noticias de cantv en el mismo costa
rica están siendo procesados
representantes de la iglesia católica
por distintos actos delictivos por
tráfico de armas por diferentes este
libro y aquí indicará tanto la excepción
no tienen color masiva si llegan a
cometer el delito como los hechos de
dementes y van a seguir del tema tienen
que ser procesados la ley es pareja para
todos y el hecho es que ellos sean
católicos representantes de la iglesia
no son inmunes no tienen no tienen
corona y respetar la ley el orden es
visto como por nuestro país
la noticia sobre todo el llamado pero
como
israel y su opinión sobre esta respuesta
que ha dado el papá francisco una
respuesta muy esperada a la comunidad
internacional en cierta forma estaba
presionando un poco al vaticano para
tomar alguna posición opinión sobre este
tema y también le parece usted que la
opinión internacional otros países de la
región han tenido una respuesta
lenta de morada tal vez un poco ambigua
ya no hay digamos un bloque de países o
de posiciones en la región
expresando algún tipo de opinión sobre
lo que está pasando en nicaragua
obviamente al pueblo nicaragüense le
resulta desesperanzador que la comunidad
internacional no se ha movido con la
beligerancia que nosotros hubiéramos
querido también desearíamos que el papá
francisco fuera a veces un poco más
explícito un poco más frontal para
denunciar los abusos que está
perpetrando la dictadura de ortega sin
embargo también tenemos que entender que
la diplomacia tiene sus tiempos y los
países siguen sus estrategias muchas
veces
buscando sobre todo
proteger los intereses de sus ciudadanos
y en este caso me imagino que el papá
también está muy preocupado por la
seguridad de los secuestrados que tiene
en sus manos la dictadura entonces no me
siento yo en autoridad de criticar al
papá si como nicaragüense desearía que
en futuras comunicaciones fueran
muchísimo más claro en su posición
porque lo que está ocurriendo
guau es absolutamente indefendible a
menos que unos a menos los
propagandistas de la dictadura que
repetirán una serie de discursos no hay
nadie con con sentido común y con dos
dedos de frente que pueda creer qué está
ocurriendo en nicaragua es democrático
es legal es justo cuando además el
régimen de ortega ni siquiera ni
siquiera es legítimo las
elecciones hubo no fueron elecciones son
un remedio de votación en donde advierte
a secuestro a todo su adversario
político tenido pegándolo ex presidente
en nicaragua es simplemente un matón que
al mando de una organización criminal
simplemente ha privatizado al estado
nicaragüense y con sus armas o sus
tropas mantiene un estado de sitio del
territorio nacional en donde cualquier
comentario disidente es visto como una
traición a la patria y se castiga con
cárcel con secuestro con exilio o con
muerte
eso sí vale la pena entender y poner en
perspectiva qué es lo que busca el
presidente ortega ya tiene 76 años lleva
ya varios años en el poder y con esta
persecución a estas 200 personas que han
ido a la cárcel que ya lo veíamos son de
diferentes sectores de la sociedad pero
también hemos visto cómo han cerrado
medios de comunicación radios locales
televisiones locales algunos periodistas
han tenido que exiliarse también
integrantes de la sociedad civil hacia
dónde va este país y qué es lo que busca
daniel ortega con esta estrategia de
persecución
social no la estamos oyendo creo que
tiene el mío activado
ok ahora dime adelante si me pregunta
acción del bajo es indicada vamos hacia
un futuro próspero que gracias a dios
que economía va mejorando aún con todo a
pesar de que el 2018 incluso con una
academia de policía deja 2000 fuertes
meta leonés de economía en la salud en
el pro pueblo pero vamos gracias a dios
superadas con qué cara van a ser un
pueblo trabajador en lucha y que saca
adelante su economía y estamos estamos
débiles no quería durando diarias
hospitales estamos inaugurando el centro
por deportiva dos carreteras gracias a
dios en busca de un sueño unir a la
cuenta caribes con el pacífico ya en una
realidad que lo hizo el gobierno el
frente sandinista en la electrificación
y el país ya está llegando al 100 por
ciento de esos llevarle recipiente
derecho a techo han jugado llevar el
derecho que tienen la educación a la
salud a la energía al lado contable
el gobierno ha hecho que es lo que el
presidente obtenga ha gustado y están
logrando como parte de la continuación
del proyecto funcionario como parte de
la segunda o tercera parte de la
revolución popular sandinista quienes
critican obviamente porque están del
otro lado de
la neoliberal en años anteriores no
miraba la falta de hacer esta fuente de
educación que hacerles continuos que la
gente se muriera afueras de una militar
porque no había ni siquiera gaza lo cual
para curar una herida es hoy olvidaron
el pasado tenebroso de los gobiernos
neoliberales y ahora críticas a empresas
la ministra porque obviamente no los
está beneficiando porque este gobierno
revolucionario está llevando en el
progreso al más necesitado nadie además
de su casa hay un refrán dicho y te dice
eso pero obviamente si vemos a 20 partes
que están en el exterior atacando y que
están llevando esta campaña de
desprestigio como el señor le evite que
te van a cómodamente se autoexilió a que
nadie lo perseguidos y que se conoce
pero él dice yo hablo mal del gobierno y
los gobiernos interés esos países están
exilio porque porque hay un tiene una
campaña entre el chile internacional en
contra de dedicar una actitud totalmente
vendepatria y de traición sin reacción a
la partida
declaró santiago de qué
nicaragua se está castigando se está
aplicando la ley a quienes no están
respetando el marco jurídico en este
país si los socios que quieran tener
intentona golpista aunque este llamado
el mandamiento del pueblo contra el
pueblo
yo le recuerdo que en la última vez que
usted estuvo en nuestro programa usted
amenazó al señor israel de vitesse en el
programa tal vez esas zonas las razones
por las que no puede estar en su país en
este momento ser el ebit es su opinión
sobre el cierre y hacia dónde se dirige
su país en esta situación en la que se
encuentra puede haber una solución
política a esto
la única solución que veo no incluye al
matrimonio ortega murillo
definitivamente que estas personas no
pueden estar en medio de un diálogo que
lleve a una solución y hacer transición
pacífica y quiero creer como te digo que
por medio de sanciones a personeros
directos de la dictadura puede ser que
él o ambos y pensar una transición pero
es una selección muy incierta
definitivamente la dictadura de ortega
se está convirtiendo una pionera de
atrocidades llegando cada vez más allá
los límites que puede tener un gobierno
soy una dictadura y es un terrible
precedente para el resto de países de la
región y eso ha dicho esto
lamento tenerlo que cortar ahí se me
acaba el tiempo del programa tengo que
darle paso al informativo yo le
agradezco mucho a xóchitl e israel- por
haber estado con nosotros haber hecho
este cara cara de la situación dos caras
de la moneda de lo que está sucediendo
en este país y bueno seguiremos atentos
con lupa lo que sucede en nicaragua en
las próximas semanas ustedes puede
seguir dejando sus comentarios y sus
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
sigan con nosotros
[Música]